só de 20 e hoje vou ensinar como fazer
um passo aqui no popular que ela tinha
prometido há algum tempo que fazer só
que não tenha encontrado o popular um
certo aqui gastei tudo pra fazer um
protótipo depois quando ia fazer um
trial já não tinha mais vantajosa
trazendo contra este caixa de um
computador da apple está em excelentes
condições e vontade para fazer o
tutorial a e proteger aquilo que é um
braço fácil caso você não tenha visto os
seus vídeos
basicamente faz o que gosta não faz mais
ou menos usando os dedos aqui em
protesto
agora vamos ao tutorial é tão bom então
vamos começar só em maio tem que
desenhar algo parecido com isso
caso você não tenha conseguido perceber
muito bem as medidas
vou deixar um link de inscrição onde eu
tirei algumas fotografias
então vocês podem ver lá com calma e
desenhar algo parecido pode ser 100%
igual porque vocês também devem ter um
braço de frente do meu como é óbvio
então você só tem primeira parte de
mecânica e depois você tá tão pra vocês
quiserem fazer o tamanho essas coisas aí
vocês podem parar que só vou usar quatro
bilhetes por que porque é difícil
controlar um dedo usando um lugar
místico gastar do lado cai então eu
consegui que vocês façam só quatro vezes
e funciona muito bem e se vocês
atentarem mais um dedo os dedos vão
ficar mais fina invoquei 1º em todo diz
ficou mais fininhos ficar mais frágeis
ok então pronto fica assim master
turismo
não acho que eu usava três meses é a que
o seu time só tem três dedos no japão
foi a pressa então protestou era cortar
o censo e as articulações deixei 55 400
e no lugar 54 centímetros enquanto
estamos tacos de ti
vejam que é bastante fácil dobrar para
fazer as articulações da orientação
aquelas partículas no popular rock está
aqui também vai estar lá a imagem no
link da inscrição
a equipe pra vocês forem o vosso braço e
vai estar lá as medidas mas convém que
vocês ajustem ao vosso modo que fique
bahia banho também não o suficiente para
ficar e estava no vosso braço da
educação claro estamos aqui agora eu vou
reforçar porque só uma camada da
população fica frágil população só tem
uma fila naquela é uma fila que já
existe um banco com 23
vocês têm que usar aqui o filme daquelas
coisas loucas e pronto eu encaixei o
brasil naquela partida e marquei meça os
dedos só que aí é só vocês escutarem ao
gênero desta vez porém bastante coloque
como eu vou cortar e depois com a volta
o marcador com muito cuidado caso você
esteja crianças peçam ajuda o duto
certeza que vai nos ajudar agora eu vou
falar aqui uns pedaços de caneta que eu
cortei vocês podem usar aquelas bolinhas
do sul só que não vai ficar tão
resistente toque de algumas linhas tão
bem frágil e quando você põe cola quente
elas ficam todas machucadas então é só
vocês por estarem produzindo de caneta é
aí podem dar-se um pouco do lixo para
tirar aquelas coisas forma quando você
discorda
agora é só pôr os rios
eu fiz aqui por um dedo mas é sempre a
mesma coisa e agora algum atuam aqui é
frágil a cair pois algumas vezes eu fico
com a tendência de fechar a mão não é
que fosse o caso do meu população mas é
provável que acontecesse com você então
é melhor vocês podem sim elástico desta
maneira aí cole num
na parte da mão e cima e depois na ponta
dos dedos
mas é só voltar a colar aquela coisa em
cima
vejam que o deic os nós de modo a poder
pôr os dedos mas se vocês quiserem podem
usar aquelas argolas do chuveiro também
ficam bairro e que não tinha então é
isso aí pessoal espero nenhum estado se
vocês quiserem dar o pênalti deixaram um
like se inscrevam para acompanhar estas
coisas que eu faço é isso
o material